we're going to begin this news on with
breaking news two Israeli settlers have
been shot dead on a main road in the
town of hawada south of nablos in the
occupied West Bank Israeli forces are
said to be searching for the suspect
sarakai right has the latest forest from
West Jerusalem what more do we know
about what's been happening Sarah
well these are two
uh today Jewish settlers living in a
settlement and they were in their car on
a highway when they were shot they
didn't die immediately but they were
critically injured and they only died
from their wounds later now the Israeli
forces say that they're still on the
hunt for the person that carried it out
a Palestinian belief to be a Palestinian
and this is in a settlement that's just
south of nablis in the occupied West
Bank now Annapolis we know on Wednesday
there were 11
Palestinians that were killed in a
massive Israeli raid including civilians
including a man that was over the age of
60 and a teenager and that in itself
caused widespread anger against uh sorry
rather with it amongst Palestinians with
lots of shops closing as a result now
with this latest attack checkpoints have
been closed and the Israeli authorities
say that they're still looking for the
person that carried it out it's also
worth noting that Hamas in Gaza has said
that it's no surprise that this attack
was carried out this is a result of
continued Israeli occupation and the
step up in their AIDS it's also the
latest incident of course in a
succession of a rising tension a week
surprise intention that we've seen
um for for quite a long time now and it
is the timing is significant because of
course there is a meeting going on in
akaba at the moment at which the
Palestinian Authority and
representatives of the Israeli
government plus representatives from the
US and other governments are trying to
find some way of de-escalating all of
this tension
yeah absolutely and this meeting is to
try and harm those tensions that have
been happening in the last few weeks
especially with this new right-wing
Israeli government that's come in there
are U.S representatives as well as
Egyptians that have tried to mediate
since the last few weeks now the the
Palestinian Authority that they're
looking at potentially giving them more
security over the occupied territory
specifically looking at nablis and
Janine where there's been a lot of
step-up raids by the Israeli authorities
a lot more demolitions and really two
hot spots where there are many armed
Palestinian men that Israel can
consistently says is reason why these
raids are happening but we also have to
look at the wider picture with this new
uh Ultra nationalist a very right-wing
government that's in intent on
increasing the number of settlements
approving 10 000 new homes in the
occupied West Bank that is increasing
these raids these demolitions just this
year alone in less than two months
you've had 65 Palestinians killed and it
already that's just one third of the
number of Palestinian kills killed last
year which was an extremely tense year
between the Israelis and Palestinians a
lot of this meeting specifically in Oman
has angered Palestinians because they
feel that the Palestinian Authority just
isn't doing enough here and there there
are concerns that by just moving
security for them to be more fully in
charge of those areas is not really
getting down to the bottom of why these
attacks are increasing why there's a lot
more tensions on the streets so
obviously we're going to be coming back
to you as we get more details about
what's been going on but for now
sarakhanna in Jerusalem thank you very
much